when seventeen-year-old Matt bags hit
the mat last weekend for the Texas high
school state wrestling championship he
found himself at the center of a
national controversy Mac is transgender
born female
but now identify his male a boy
wrestling girls
yeah people might have booed because I
knew there was aa the South's favorite
pastime hating what they don't
understand that f2m high school state
champ is Mac and they're not so great
people at Texas force him to wrassle
girls because you have to compete
against the gender listed on your birth
certificate according to the Bible being
transgender is a delicate topic so who
better than me a cisgender mono amorous
binary am a be heterosexual to mansplain
the many issues faced in the trans
community or would you prefer nor
McDonnell do it he she they are there I
don't care what pronoun people use for
me as long as they don't look me in the
eyes the most important way I identify
is rich maybe if the carolinas were a
little more tolerant the Lord wouldn't
hammer them with hurricanes I just don't
want to be in a stall next to someone
who cares which bathroom trans people
use no one wants to molest you do a
Hicks especially not while you're taking
one of your greasy fast food dumps don't
discriminate against Mac because these
trans do it because he's got a cute
girlfriend and a creepy mustache he's
the whole package even though he doesn't
have a whole package yeah but if Justin
Bieber can turn into a gross man
overnight
why can't Matt that's why I gave him a
ride in my sweet Trans Am for this
week's ce-web-rity profile
[Applause]
what are you doing huh
all right cauliflower mayor trying to
make weight get rid of all my fluid
you know earwax has fewer calories and
ranch I didn't not know that look it up
dude Mac nice to meet you nice to meet
you welcome to my underground high
school wrestling club where I'm open to
wrestling all genders as long as you're
in high school but no one of those
special needs kids it's like 25 they're
too strong
oh how I'm glad to be here would it be
fair to say God cock-blocked you how did
you come up with that name man well my
real name was actually McKenzie I just
went by mac mac and cheese Matt
Macklemore little Matt cuz I'm like 5
foot 2 you're a tiny little fella yeah
you want to talk about a cruel twist of
fate with God Texas Texas is actually
pretty cool you enjoy Texas I enjoy
actually when did you say all right this
wasn't the hand that I was dealt well I
was like okay I feel different
well maybe I didn't know what to call it
so I came out bisexual what age is this
yes great I was at recess and I like
came out so like my closest friends
uh-huh
next thing you know they're just like
like it to everybody out in people's not
a good thing
nah but in fifth grade I think it's just
so hard to keep a juicy secret no
everyone was like I was like oh and then
seventh grade I was like I actually feel
different and then my mom we were in the
car and she watched this Katie Couric
show or whatever sure and it was about
trans kids and she was like do you feel
like you're a guy and I was like I
thought it was weird so I was like why
are you asking me these questions like
13 14 2004 a different if you put on
weight is it considered trans fat
no I talked to me about the whole
process of transitioning I started out
with taking my shots first you do the
shots in the ass where do they go
legs I always do anything like you given
to yourself yeah just one today what is
it one is like that much testosterone
what about your voice are you doing a
voice or is that your voice in my voice
can you sing my girlfriend likes to
think so but I disagree how are you been
dating her by the way can I call her a
smoke show how old is she
yeah she's a succeed scratch that let's
not call her smoke you so you were
forced from day one to wrestle in the
female division but in high school you
were identified as a man the whole time
did you ever lose to a girl oh yeah you
did yeah where she white oh she's
absolutely skin nurse again maybe a lot
of Puerto Rican Texans are there's poor
Rican Salvadorians call them same thing
in my school you'll be killed Oh
gotcha gotcha hard line do they force
you to use the girls locker room they
didn't force me I are you chose to be
the only transgender kid in your school
I was and then more people started
coming down in the high school
did you ever secretly get mad like hey
man this is this is my thing now you
just had your your breasts removed
yeah did you have big boobs to begin
with no when I had to single it on like
it looks like how like I am now
look like Phil Mickelson he's a golfer I
don't like it good you're gonna see him
in shirts and I'm like that doesn't look
right
I think he actually might have gotten it
fixed can we do a before and after and
tell me if Phil Mickelson had the chest
worked on all right back to you did you
get one last squeeze before you got rid
of him or no no I
you had a titty twister yet no no I may
be the first guy we go at the same time
we see who let's go first oh you know
fine it can be on well I have a feeling
I know where it is unless your doctor is
completely insane
do you like boobs as a man oh yeah
totally
BYOT I'm all about that you're an ass
man all right that's good that's mature
of you
you can do the bottom or no yeah I'm
nothing anybody what do they do there's
one to where the plate will get bigger
uh-huh you have a big one thing you have
a big dick if you have a small it's
gonna be small but how much more is that
surgery cost probably like 25 grand 30
grand for a tiny I'm guessing that's
that so that's a gamble right there and
then the other surgery is I have to take
part of either to skin on my thigh or
somewhere on my body and then they shape
it and then they attach it you should
have saved your boobs do they create
balls and that's a question I probably
need to look at myself I don't give any
guy friends that just let you like
really like take a good look and like
figure stuff out
balls are confusing evening I don't know
man look I know but okay so that are in
this sack and you can't you can't switch
him to the other sack you think you can
work one of the balls over and you do it
you try as a kid over and over you try
to see if you can shove it in the other
say but it doesn't it doesn't go pretty
sure one of my friends would be up to it
cuz he's just like that and he's just
weird and the group that I'm with right
now my buds they're actually my sister's
friends before and so is your sister
older younger she's just like a year
younger than me were you prettier than
she was no she definitely got the looks
she got the looks and you're gonna get
the penis
you showed her what's your tattoo me
House of the Rising Sun
are you finished getting tattoos no you
can cover your whole body are you guys
gonna weigh in or not yeah yes I'm ready
Oh think thin Mac is weighing in at 125
[Music]
daniel is 183
I'm 25 ah there second there are thugs
man to lop off half my dog to drop 60
pounds nut sure cotton-candy illegal
bets not just cuttin candy illegal bets
not chose cotton candy
and Mac you're about to get testosterone
[Music]
they can set a loop
[Applause]
rustle boys I'm sorry
Haley's a lose to a girl that's pretty
walk with me to let you win now the best
part of being a man
showering together I respect you as a
man let you wrestle a bitch I mean
that's technically a hate crime
[Applause]